You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那些台阶。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去浪迹天涯了！或者你也可以在希尔顿预定房间。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Anyone can be targeted by a financial scammer, but many older adults are especially at risk. Scams targeting people over age 60 cost victims more than $3.4 billion in 2023,
希尔顿特卖会正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿App上预定，即可享受高达8折的优惠，获得你期望的住宿体验。当你想要的是实惠，而不是惊吓。住哪里很关键。希尔顿，伴你每一次住宿。任何人都有可能成为金融诈骗的目标，但许多老年人尤其面临风险。根据FBI网络犯罪投诉中心的数据，
according to the FBI's Internet Crime Complaints Center. The average victim lost nearly $34,000. Not all older adults are at high risk, but researchers are finding that financial vulnerability could be an early sign of cognitive impairment or even Alzheimer's disease. So how prevalent is financial fraud and abuse? What vulnerability factors put some older adults at particular risk? What's the connection between financial vulnerability and changes in the brain?
针对60岁以上人群的诈骗在2023年给受害者造成了超过34亿美元的损失。受害者平均损失近3.4万美元。并非所有老年人都面临高风险，但研究人员发现，财务脆弱性可能是认知受损甚至阿尔茨海默病的早期迹象。那么，金融欺诈和滥用的普遍程度如何？有哪些脆弱性因素使某些老年人面临特别高的风险？财务脆弱性与大脑变化之间有什么联系？
And what can people do to protect themselves and their loved ones from falling victim to a scammer? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Today we're coming to you from Denver, Colorado, where APA is meeting for its 2025 annual convention. My guest today is Dr. Duke Hahn, who will be speaking at the convention later this week.
人们可以做些什么来保护自己和所爱的人免受诈骗分子的侵害？欢迎收看《心理学热线》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们从科罗拉多州丹佛市为您进行报道，APA正在这里召开2025年年会。我今天的嘉宾是杜克·韩（Duke Hahn）博士，他将于本周晚些时候在大会上发言。
Dr. Hahn is a professor of psychology, family medicine, neurology, and gerontology at the University of Southern California. He is a board-certified clinical neuropsychologist, an APA fellow and a fellow of the National Academy, of neuropsychology. His research focuses on factors that affect cognition and decision-making and aging with particular interest in financial decision-making. His work has been featured in many media outlets, including CNN, Reuters, and PBS. Dr. Holland, thank you for joining me today. Oh, thanks for having me, Kim. This is great. I'm a big fan of the show, and so it's good to be here.
韩博士是南加州大学的心理学、家庭医学、神经病学和老年学教授。他是美国特许临床神经心理学家、APA会士以及国家神经心理学学会会士。他的研究重点是影响老龄化认知和决策的因素，对财务决策有着特别的兴趣。他的工作曾在CNN、路透社和PBS等许多媒体上亮相。韩博士，非常感谢您今天能来。哦，谢谢邀请我，金。这太棒了。我是这个节目的超级粉丝，很高兴能来到这里。
Oh, thank you. So let me start by asking you how common are financial scams and predators, especially the ones who prey on older adults. Do we know, for instance, how many or what percentage of people might be victimized in their lifetime? We don't have great numbers on this. And the reason for that is because there aren't any central tracking programs
哦，谢谢你。那么我先问你，金融诈骗和掠夺有多普遍，特别是那些以老年人为目标的诈骗？比如，我们知道一生中可能会有多少人或多大比例的人沦为受害者吗？关于这一点，我们并没有确切的数据。原因在于，目前还没有任何来自政府或其他地方的集中追踪程序
from the government or elsewhere that have been effective in tracking how bad of a problem this has been. Now, we know from research that people report this in about 5 to 10% of the older adult population. But many of us who do research in this area think this is a hugely underestimation
能够有效地追踪这个问题到底有多严重。现在，我们从研究中得知，大约有5%到10%的老年人口报告了这种情况。但许多在该领域进行研究的人认为，这被严重低估了。
of what this problem actually is in our country. And really, no one really knows how prevalent this is. I will say I give talks on this topic frequently, and after each talk, a number of people come up to me and say that this has happened in their life, in their family. And so I think it's a lot more prevalent than what we think. What are the most common types of scams, and are most of these scams online now, or are they still happening by phone or even snail mail? So it's interesting. The prevalence of scams seem to be very focused on the age range, actually, of the victim.
实际上，在我们国家这个问题到底有多严重，没有人真正知道。我得说，我经常就这个话题做演讲，每次演讲结束后，都会有许多人走过来对我说，这种事在他们的生活、他们的家庭中发生过。所以我认为这比我们想象的要普遍得多。最常见的诈骗类型是什么？现在这些诈骗大多是在线进行的，还是仍然通过电话甚至传统信件发生？所以这很有趣。诈骗的普遍性似乎非常集中在受害者的年龄段上。
And so in, I would say, early older age, there is a lot of prevalent email scam, phone scam. If you go a little bit older, phone scam becomes more. prevalent and less electronic scams just because I think there's less utilization. And then in the oldest age groups, believe it or not, snail mail is actually one of the most prevalent ways to scam older adults. And I think it's, again, because it's just more utilized. And how would that work? I mean, snail mail, it feels so ancient these days. I mean, somebody sends you a letter and says, you know, give me all your money. There's lots of really sad cases of older adults being sent letters, saying, you know, help support this issue or this cause and those causes being bogus, actually. And so because older adults are very generous and kind, they often end up responding to those
因此，在进入老龄初期时，有很多电子邮件诈骗和电话诈骗。如果再年长一些，电话诈骗会变得更普遍，电子诈骗相对减少，我想这只是因为使用率变低了。然后到了最高年龄段，信不信由你，传统信件实际上是诈骗老年人最普遍的方式之一。我想这同样是因为它被使用得更多。那这是怎么运作的呢？我是说，传统信件，这些天感觉太古老了。我是说，有人给你寄一封信，说，你知道的，把你的所有钱都给我。有许多非常令人痛心的案例，老年人收到信件，说，你知道的，帮助支持这个议题或这个原因，而这些原因实际上是虚假的。因此，由于老年人非常慷慨和善良，他们最终往往会对这些
calls for financial support. And I think I can share this, that the Postmaster, this is something that the Postmaster has to do with on a pretty wide scale. And so they are very interested in trying to address this in particularly older adults. Are most of the scammers strangers, or do people get scammed just as often by friends and relatives? So we have done some research in using some available databases to see how prevalent the type of scammer or what type of scammer might be committing these crimes. And it does seem to be the case, at least in certain crimes that family members, unfortunately, are very commonly, the ones that are perpetrating this. Now that being said, we also know that scam and fraud is very prevalent from electronic or stranger-based locations. And so a lot of these are actually
要求经济支持的呼吁作出回应。我想我可以分享这一点，邮政局长——这是邮政局长必须在相当大的范围内处理的事情。因此，他们对试图解决这个问题非常感兴趣，特别是针对老年人。诈骗者大多是陌生人，还是人们被朋友和亲戚诈骗的频率同样高？所以我们利用一些可用的数据库进行了一些研究，以了解诈骗者的类型有多普遍，或者可能是什么类型的诈骗者在犯下这些罪行。确实有这样的情况，至少在某些犯罪中，家庭成员不幸地是非常普遍的行骗者。话虽如此，我们也知道来自电子或陌生人渠道的诈骗和欺诈也非常普遍。因此，其中许多实际上是
from outside the United States just trying to scam older adults in the United States. So there really is a range. And again, we don't really have great data to know how prevalent what type of scammer is versus another. You know, I have an acquaintance who I think right now is being scammed by somebody. And this person started out as a stranger, and now he thinks he's having some kind of an online relationship with a woman who is probably some, you know, strange man in a foreign country. I mean, is that a very common technique that works well, particularly with older people? Sure, yeah. So this is a common scam known as a romance scam, or it could be a romance scam. It doesn't have to be even romantically involved, just some sort of interpersonal relationship
来自美国境外，专门试图诈骗美国的老年人。所以确实各种情况都有。同样，我们并没有很好的数据来了解哪种类型的诈骗者比另一种更普遍。你知道，我有一个熟人，我认为他现在正被某人诈骗。这个人最初是个陌生人，现在他以为自己和一个女人在进行某种网络恋爱，而这个女人可能是一个身处异国的陌生男子。我的意思是，这是一种非常普遍且效果很好的技巧吗？特别对老年人来说？当然，是的。所以这是一种被称为“杀猪盘”的常见骗局，或者可能是浪漫骗局。甚至不一定非要涉及恋爱关系，只是一种人际关系
scam. And unfortunately, loneliness and social isolation is one of the biggest risk factors for a scam or fraud or financial exploitation vulnerability. And so this is a scenario where a stranger will try to become more familiar with an older adult because that older adult has more resources, and that older adult might be feeling more lonely and may be very responsive to those overtures. That's a situation where you don't necessarily need to have any cognitive impairment involved. it could be sheerly just an older adult feeling more lonely and more isolated. And in those cases, it's sad because often these strangers become very close to these older adults and these older adults trust these strangers, these bad actors, with a lot more of their resources
骗局。不幸的是，孤独和社会隔离是遭受诈骗、欺诈或财务剥削脆弱性的最大风险因素之一。因此，在这种情况下，陌生人会试图与老年人变得更熟悉，因为该老年人拥有更多资源，而且该老年人可能会感到更加孤独，并且可能对这些主动示好做出强烈反应。在这种情况下，不一定需要涉及任何认知受损。可能纯粹只是一个老年人感到更加孤独和孤立。在这些情况下，令人痛心的是，这些陌生人往往与这些老年人变得非常亲密，而这些老年人却将他们的大部分资源
than they should. And so these are situations that are fairly common that we hear about. So your clinical neuropsychologist, what got you interested in financial vulnerability? I had always been interested in the earliest signs of Alzheimer's disease. And from a cognition standpoint, I had always been interested in what are the first signs of cognitive decline that might indicate Alzheimer's disease down the road. And that's been a basis of my research for many years. And at the same time, I was seeing patients for dementia evaluations. And I remember vividly at one point in my career where I had a patient referred one after the other because it was presumed they had
信任给了这些陌生人和坏演员，超出了他们应该给的范围。因此，这些是我们经常听说的相当普遍的情况。那么，作为一名临床神经心理学家，是什么让你对财务脆弱性产生兴趣的？我一直对阿尔茨海默病的早期迹象很感兴趣。从认知的角度来看，我一直对可能是未来阿尔茨海默病征兆的认知衰退的第一批迹象感兴趣。多年来，这一直是我的研究基础。与此同时，我在看痴呆症评估的患者。我生动地记得我职业生涯中的某个时刻，我接诊的患者一个接一个被转诊过来，因为人们推测他们有
dementia because it was discovered they were giving away large sums of money to a stranger, just like we had been talking about. And that was a change in behavior that had never happened before. And there was this general presumption from the family and the medical providers, oh, this is actually early dementia. Let's get it diagnosed. And so they would send me these patients. And I would do hours of testing on these patients and they would test cognitively normal. And so clearly there had been a change in behavior. Our cognitive tests weren't picking up on the fact that there was any cognitive impairment. And so that was a bit of a disconnect.
痴呆症，因为人们发现他们把巨额钱财送给了一个陌生人，就像我们一直在谈论的那样。那是以前从未发生过的行为改变。家属和医疗提供者普遍推测，哦，这实际上是早期痴呆症。让我们确诊一下。所以他们把这些患者送来。我会对这些患者进行几个小时的测试，结果显示他们的认知完全正常。因此，显然行为发生了改变。我们的认知测试并没有检测出存在任何认知受损。所以这有点脱节。
And often the family and the medical providers were disappointed because it just made things less clear. The patient often loved it because it gave them license to keep doing what they were doing. But for me, as a clinical neuropsychologist, it made me realize there's really a lot that we just don't understand about the relationship of financial decision-making in older age and cognition and early Alzheimer's disease or early dementia. And so that got me thinking, could this be one of the earliest signs of dementia even before any cognitive impairment is noticed? And I was working with Alzheimer's Research Center at the time, the Rush Alzheimer's Disease Center, which is an amazing center based out of Chicago. They had started doing research studies on this topic. and then one thing led to another,
通常家属和医疗提供者会感到失望，因为这让事情变得更加模糊不清。患者通常很喜欢这样，因为它给了他们继续这样做的通行证。但对我来说，作为一名临床神经心理学家，这让我意识到，对于老年时期的财务决策与认知以及早期阿尔茨海默病或早期痴呆症之间的关系，我们确实还有很多不理解的地方。这让我开始思考：这会不会是痴呆症的最早迹象之一，甚至在注意到任何认知受损之前就出现了？当时我正与阿尔茨海默病研究中心合作，即拉什阿尔茨海默病中心（Rush Alzheimer's Disease Center），这是一个位于芝加哥的了不起的中心。他们当时已经开始就这个主题进行研究。然后事情顺理成章，
and it sort of took off as a research focus from that point on. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Hahn about his recent research on financial vulnerability as an early sign of Alzheimer's disease. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing.
从那时起，它作为一个研究重点迅速发展起来。我们要进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与韩博士讨论他最近关于将财务脆弱性作为阿尔茨海默病早期迹象的研究。现在是盛花授粉季，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。即使蜂窝网络再拥挤，我的连接依然保持强劲。
Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill,
此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为35美元/月。这绝对是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索Google Fi Wireless套餐。另需税费和政府规费。在网络高使用率期间，Google Fi Wireless不受数据流量降速限制。家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠为您开启盛夏。是时候用Next Grills的
four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199.9. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49.9. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, pricing invalid May 14th or May 27, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. So since then, some of your research has found that there is a connection between financial vulnerability and early signs of Alzheimer's disease in the brain. Can you tell us about that work? So we had a study recently published that focused on older adults that had no signs of cognitive impairment,
四烧气炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅售199.9美元；还可以搭配汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅，仅售49.9美元，整季尽享娱乐时光。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国适用。详情请参见HomeDepot.com/pricematch。那么自那以后，你的一些研究发现财务脆弱性与大脑中阿尔茨海默病的早期迹象之间存在联系。你能跟我们聊聊这项工作吗？我们最近发表了一项研究，重点关注没有认知受损迹象的老年人，
but also varied with respect to their financial vulnerability status. And in this study, we found that a brain region called the enterrinal cortex was thinner in older adults who were more vulnerable to financial scam and fraud. And again, this was in a group of people with no cognitive impairment. And so another aspect to this particular study in this particular brain region that's important to understand is that this brain region, the entirino cortex, is commonly known as one of the first brain regions to be impacted by Alzheimer's disease neuropathology. So what we saw in this study was that older adults who had thinner enterrinal cortex, presumably because they were starting to accumulate, Alzheimer's disease neuropathology showed greater vulnerability to financial scam and fraud. And again, these are older adults who had no cognitive impairment.
但他们在财务脆弱性状态方面也各不相同。在这项研究中，我们发现，对于那些更容易受到金融诈骗和欺诈侵害的老年人来说，一个被称为内嗅皮层（entorhinal cortex）的大脑区域更薄。再次强调，这是在一群没有认知受损的人当中发现的。关于这项特定研究和这个需要理解的重要特定大脑区域，另一个方面是，这个大脑区域，即内嗅皮层，通常被称为最早受到阿尔茨海默病神经病理学影响的大脑区域之一。因此，在这项研究中我们看到的是，内嗅皮层较薄的老年人——据推测是因为他们开始积累阿尔茨海默病神经病理学——对金融诈骗和欺诈表现出更大的脆弱性。再次强调，这些是没有认知受损的老年人。
So this helps us understand why certain older adults might show poor financial decision-making ahead of any noticeable cognitive impairment. It could be that they're showing brain changes consistent with early Alzheimer's disease before any noticeable memory decline. Now, I'll also say that the entourage. coronal cortex is an important brain region for financial decision making because it connects a brain network that helps us imagine future outcomes. So it also connects another brain network that helps us assess the value of certain things, the value of certain outcomes. And so you can imagine if an older adult
这有助于我们理解为什么某些老年人可能在出现任何明显的认知受损之前就表现出糟糕的财务决策能力。可能是因为他们在出现任何明显的记忆衰退之前，就表现出与早期阿尔茨海默病一致的大脑变化。现在，我还想说，内嗅皮层是进行财务决策的重要大脑区域，因为它连接了一个帮助我们想象未来结果的大脑网络。它还连接了另一个帮助我们评估某些事物价值、某些结果价值的大脑网络。因此你可以想象，如果一个老年人
has thinning brain in this particular region that helps connect the ability to imagine certain outcomes and the ability to assess appropriate value, that that particular older adult might be more vulnerable to scam and fraud and financial exploitation. So all of these things come together to really help explain why certain older adults might show poor financial decisions ahead of any noticeable cognitive impairment.
在这个特定的、有助于连接想象某些结果的能力和评估适当价值能力的脑区出现大脑变薄，那么这个特定的老年人可能更容易受到诈骗、欺诈和财务剥削。因此，所有这些因素结合在一起，真正有助于解释为什么某些老年人可能在出现任何明显的认知受损之前就表现出糟糕的财务决策。
It could be that they're showing less thickness of the entranal cortex because this is commonly known to be one of the first brain regions impacted by Alzheimer's disease. Do any of the people you've studied have sort of a cognizance of their own that something is going wrong? I mean, they may have, you know, begin to understand that they're giving away their money, and are they beginning to see also that perhaps they're losing some of their executive function? This is something that we often get asked by people outside of our research program,
可能是因为他们表现出较薄的内嗅皮层，因为这通常被称为受阿尔茨海默病影响的第一批大脑区域之一。你研究过的所有人中，有没有人对自己身上正在发生某些不对劲的事情有所认知？我的意思是，他们可能已经开始明白自己在把钱送出去，他们是否也开始看到自己可能正在失去一些执行功能？这是我们在研究项目之外经常被人们问到的问题，
you know, how come these older adults don't know that they're making these. poor financial decisions. In our research, it's been interesting. We've been trying to delve into that a bit more. Many older adults don't really think they're making poor financial decisions. And so there is that lack of insight potentially in what they're doing. In a really interesting twist, I think, some older adults fully are able to articulate that they're making poor financial decisions, and they still do it. Even if you explain to these older adults, well, you just told me that this is probably not a good decision. Why do you keep doing it? They'll say things like, well, it's because I just want to.
你知道，为什么这些老年人在做出这些糟糕的财务决策时自己却不知道呢？在我们的研究中，这很有趣。我们一直在试图更深入地探讨这一点。许多老年人并不认为自己是在做糟糕的财务决策。因此，他们在自己所做的事情上可能缺乏这种洞察力。我认为有一个非常有趣的转折，一些老年人完全能够清楚地表达他们正在做出糟糕的财务决策，但他们仍然这样做。即使你向这些老年人解释，好吧，你刚刚告诉我这可能不是一个好决定。为什么还要继续这样做？他们会说这样的话，嗯，这是因为我就是想这么做。
And so some might argue maybe that is still a lack of insight, actually. But honestly, we still haven't really fully understood the link between insight and financial decisions. But it's something that we're hoping to learn more about. So it's not always a sign of Alzheimer's or any other kind of mental decline when these things are happening, but is something else going on in people's brains or they're just are gullible and they're just looking for a friend? They trust somebody and then they decide to give away their life savings. So we've been doing this work for quite some time now, and we do believe that a portion of older adults do show brain changes that are consistent with early dementia ahead of any noticeable cognitive decline.
所以有人可能会争辩说，也许这仍然是一种缺乏洞察力的表现。但老实说，我们仍然没有完全理解洞察力与财务决策之间的联系。这是我们希望了解更多的内容。所以当这些事情发生时，它并不总是阿尔茨海默病或其他任何心理衰退的迹象，但人们的大脑中是否发生了其他事情，或者他们只是容易受骗，只是在寻找一个朋友？他们信任某人，然后决定把一生的积蓄送出去？所以我们做这项工作已经有一段时间了，我们确实相信一部分老年人确实表现出与早期痴呆症一致的大脑变化，发生在任何明显的认知衰退之前。
Now that being said, we also believe that some older adults may not show any brain changes consistent with dementia or and might be showing poor financial decision making for other reasons such as they may be lonely or they may be socially isolated. Doing this work for a number of years now, I've grown to appreciate there really is a host of different reasons why certain older adults might make poor financial decisions in certain situations. Now I do need to also stress that it's really just a portion of older adults that might be more vulnerable to scam or fraud or financial exploitation. Also in this work, I've come across the notion that some believe that as we grow older, we're all going
话虽如此，我们也相信一些老年人可能不会表现出与痴呆症一致的大脑变化，而可能是出于其他原因表现出糟糕的财务决策，比如他们可能感到孤独或社会隔离。从事这项工作多年来，我逐渐认识到，为什么某些老年人在某些情况下会做出糟糕的财务决策，确实有各种各样不同的原因。现在我还需要强调的是，只有一部分老年人可能更容易受到诈骗、欺诈或财务剥削。同样在这项工作中，我偶然听到这样一种观点：有些人认为，随着我们变老，我们所有人都会
to be poor financial decision makers, we're all going to be more susceptible to scam or fraud, and I emphatically have to say that that's not the case. There's lots of data it to support, actually, the vast majority of older adults won't even show cognitive impairment as they grow older. They'll just show normal cognition with respect to their age. And so I did want to just take a brief aside and say that way of thinking is, in my opinion, very ageist. It's not that all older adults are going to show poor financial decision making or even show
成为糟糕的财务决策者，我们所有人都更容易受到诈骗或欺诈的影响，我必须明确指出，事实并非如此。实际上有大量数据支持，绝大多数老年人在变老时甚至不会表现出认知受损。对于他们的年龄来说，他们只会表现出正常的认知。所以我想顺便简短地说一下，这种思维方式在我看来是非常年龄歧视的。并不是所有老年人都会表现出糟糕的财务决策，甚至表现出
cognitive impairment, but we do believe that a portion of older adults may become more vulnerable to scam or fraud or financial exploitations because of brain changes or because of other risk factors such as loneliness and others that we've studied throughout the years. What can people do to protect themselves or what can their family members do to protect other members of their family as they're aging? We do believe that some older adults may show brain changes consistent with early Alzheimer's disease or dementia or cognitive decline. And so I think monitoring of cognition and brain health, just a focus on brain health and older age
认知受损，但我们确实相信，一部分老年人可能会因为大脑变化或其他风险因素（如孤独以及我们多年来研究的其他因素）而变得更容易受到诈骗、欺诈或财务剥削。人们可以做些什么来保护自己，或者他们的家庭成员可以在长辈变老时做些什么来保护家中的其他成员？我们确实相信，一些老年人可能会表现出与早期阿尔茨海默病、痴呆症或认知衰退一致的大脑变化。因此，我认为监测认知和大脑健康，专注于老年时期的大脑健康
is one way to address this for all older adults. We had been talking about social isolation. That's another risk factor. It's a very strong risk factor in the elder abuse research world. It predisposes certain older adults to abuse and financial exploitation. So another way that an older adult could be protected or at least this could be less of an issue is reducing a social isolation of older adults, increasing frequency of contact, developing meaningful relationships.
是所有老年人应对这一问题的方法之一。我们之前一直在谈论社会隔离。这是另一个风险因素。在虐待老人研究领域，这是一个非常强大的风险因素。它使某些老年人更容易遭受虐待和财务剥削。因此，保护老年人或至少减少这一问题严重性的另一种方法是减少老年人的社会隔离，增加联系频率，建立有意义的关系。
We have a study showing that it's not just how many people an older adult knows that is protective. It's really how deep of a relationship they have with even just a few people. That aspect is protective against financial scam and fraud. Other things like general health promoting behaviors are helpful. So, for example, we have a study showing that frailty is associated with higher financial exploitation vulnerability and older age, and by frailty, specifically hearing and seeing. So even just staying on top of declines in vision or especially declines in hearing,
我们有一项研究表明，保护老年人的不仅仅是他们认识多少人。真正起到保护作用的是他们与仅仅几个人之间建立的关系有多深。这一方面可以防止金融诈骗和欺诈。其他诸如促进总体健康的习惯之类的事情也很有帮助。例如，我们有一项研究表明，虚弱与晚年更高的财务剥削脆弱性相关，这里说的虚弱具体是指听力和视力。因此，哪怕只是应对视力下降，尤其是听力下降，
the use of hearing aids and things like that are going to protect older adults against scam or fraud or financial exploitation. Also, just general awareness that these things are happening is a good thing. thing. So education programs that bring awareness about scam and fraud of older adults, this podcast that we're doing right now, any media interest, I think that helps bring attention to this matter. The more that the word gets out, I think this helps to bring attention to things that could be scammer or fraud. It also helps, I think, to reduce some of the stigma and the shame, because this is truly something that can happen to anyone. It's not, it doesn't mean that you're going to develop Alzheimer's disease or that you have poor cognition. Anyone can make a poor decision.
使用助听器之类的事情，也能保护老年人免受诈骗、欺诈或财务剥削。此外，只要普遍意识到这些事情正在发生就是一件好事。因此，提高老年人对诈骗和欺诈认识的教育项目、我们现在正在做的这个播客、任何媒体的关注，我认为这都有助于引起人们对这个问题的关注。消息传得越广，我认为这就越有助于引起人们对可能是诈骗或欺诈的事物的注意。我认为这也有助于减少一些耻辱感和羞耻感，因为这确实是可能发生在大闸任何人身上的事情。这并不意味着你会得阿尔茨海默病，或者你的认知能力很差。任何人都可能做出糟糕的决定。
I can tell you in our own research, we have very highly educated doctors and lawyers, participants in our research program. So it can happen to anyone. It's really not something that is going to happen just because you grow older. So stories like this, I think, go a long way to help reducing the stigma and the shame behind this when it does happen. And then I will say, finally, if it does happen, I would encourage anyone listening to report it. There's lots of reporting methods now. So Ic3.gov is something that was developed by the government. It's ic3.gov is the website. And that's to report any sort of internet scam or fraud. The Senate has a hotline about this. AARP has the Fraud Watch program, which has a number of different
我可以告诉你，在我们的研究中，参与我们研究项目的有受过高等教育的医生和律师。所以这可能发生在任何人身上。这真的不是仅仅因为你变老了才会发生的事。因此，像这样的故事，我认为对于帮助减少发生这种情况时背后的耻辱感和羞耻感大有帮助。最后我要说的是，如果它真的发生了，我鼓励任何听到的人去举报。现在有很多举报方法。所以Ic3.gov是政府开发的一个网站。网址是ic3.gov。那是用来举报任何网络诈骗或欺诈的。参议院有一条关于此事的求助热线。美国退休人员协会（AARP）有“欺诈观察”（Fraud Watch）项目，其中有许多不同的
resources to try to address this. So if unfortunately it does happen, I would encourage anyone to please report it, because in the reporting, that helps to protect others from the same fate. And I think at least I know my financial institutions ask me to have a designated other person on a lot of my accounts so that somebody else would have the ability to look in and not really do anything, but know if something strange were happening. Yes. And I think programs like that go a long way to help. And I think if older adults are willing to engage in those programs, I think, again, it's the more people that are involved that are looking out for the welfare of older adults, I think that actually goes a long way to help protect against really this
资源来试图解决这个问题。因此，如果不幸发生了，我鼓励任何人去举报，因为通过举报，有助于保护其他人免受同样的命运。我想，至少我知道我的金融机构要求我在我的很多账户上指定另一个人，这样另一个人就有权查看情况，虽然不能真的做什么，但如果发生奇怪的事情，他们能知道。是的。我认为这样的项目对提供帮助大有帮助。而且我认为如果老年人愿意参与这些项目，我认为，同样，参与寻找和关注老年人福祉的人越多，我认为这对于抵御目前正在发生的针对老年人的
epidemic of scam and frog among older adults, which is happening right now. Are there other policy changes that you think might help prevent these scams? There are many in our field that believe that having harsher penalties for people who commit these crimes might be helpful. That could help. I actually, it's not my area, so we can't really speak to that. We had mentioned some of the public education programs, I think, go a long way to help address this. In terms of policy, I think we started off this conversation with the fact that there aren't really great trekking programs. And if there was a great trekking program, one that would help older adults feel less shame and guilt about experiencing this and being able to report that so that we can track and see how bad this problem is and have real good data, I think that would go a long way to help address this problem as well.
诈骗和欺诈的流行病大有帮助。你认为还有哪些政策变化可能有助于防止这些诈骗？我们领域的许多人认为，对犯下这些罪行的人进行更严厉的惩罚可能会有所帮助。这可能会有帮助。实际上，这不是我的领域，所以我们无法真正谈论这一点。我们提到过一些公共教育项目，我认为这对于帮助解决这个问题大有帮助。在政策方面，我想我们开始这场对话时提到了这样一个事实，即并没有真正很好的追踪程序。如果有了一个很好的追踪程序，一个能帮助老年人减少因经历这一切而产生的羞耻感和内疚感，并能够进行举报的程序，这样我们就可以追踪并了解这个问题的严重程度，并拥有真正好的数据，我认为这对于帮助解决这个问题也将大有帮助。
What else you're working on right now? Where are the other big questions that you want to answer as a neuropsychologist? We are still pursuing this as a potential early marker of Alzheimer's disease dementia. And so one of the things that we're doing right now is we're developing ways to actually look and use very, very new blood tests that have been developed for Alzheimer's disease specifically. So we're hoping to incorporate some of these blood tests in our research. We are still very much interested in early brain changes. We're still very much interested in all the other factors outside the brain.
你现在还在做什么？作为一名神经心理学家，你想回答的其他重大问题是什么？我们仍在继续将其作为阿尔茨海默病痴呆症的潜在早期标志进行研究。因此，我们目前正在做的事情之一是开发方法来实际观察和使用为阿尔茨海默病专门开发的最非常新的血液检测。所以我们希望将其中一些血液检测纳入我们的研究中。我们仍然非常关注早期的大脑变化。我们仍然非常关注大脑外部的所有其他因素。
So social relationships, social isolation, medical health, other factors, other contextual factors. We are very interested in how this might look in different underrepresented people groups. And so that's something that we really don't have great data at all on. And we know that generally speaking, older minorized people groups are targeted more, or they experience more scam or fraud. And we need to know that why that's the case. And we need to try to address that. So these are just some of the questions that we're trying to focus on in the future.
因此，社会关系、社会隔离、医疗健康、其他因素、其他背景因素。我们非常关注这在不同的代表性不足的人群中可能是怎样的。因此，这是我们完全没有很好数据的一个方面。我们知道，总的来说，年长的少数族裔群体更容易成为目标，或者他们经历更多的诈骗或欺诈。我们需要知道为什么会这样。我们需要努力解决这个问题。这些只是我们试图在未来重点关注的一些问题。
Dr. Hahn, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's really been great seeing you here in Denver. Yeah, really great being here with you, Kim. And thanks again for having me on your program, a big fan. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
韩博士，我要感谢你今天能来。在丹佛见到你真是太棒了。是的，很高兴能在这里和你在一起，金。再次感谢邀请我参加你的节目，我是个超级粉丝。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.com上找到《心理学热线》之前的节目。或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发邮件给我们：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学热线》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。